We do begin this morning
with the war in Ukraine.
Russia launching
a barrage of missiles
overnight across Ukraine.
Power knocked out,
innocent civilians killed.
It is the largest scale bombardm
we have seen in nearly a month.
The Russians
struck several
major cities,
including the capital Kiev,
far away from the front lines.
Ukrainian officials
say a Russian missile
obliterated these homes and kill
at least five people
in the western city of Lviv,
which is right on NATO's doorste
This is a photo
of Russian missiles
rising up into the sky
in the pre-dawn hours.
Ukraine's military says Russia l
more than 80 missiles in all.
And Europe's largest
nuclear power plant in Japan,
Russia has been completely disco
now from Ukraine's power grid
because of that Russian shelling
That's according to the energy c
that runs it.
So we do begin with our Ivan Wat
He is live on the ground in Kiev
Just a barrage overnight and so
What can you tell us
Good morning, Poppy.
And according to the Ukrainian
military command,
this was a massive missile attac
on Ukraine's critical infrastruc
And I'm just going to give you
a little image
of some of the consequences of t
A security source in Ukraine
says that this was a piece of a
that burned out these cars.
It hit around
6:00 this morning before dawn
and would have been
absolutely terrifying.
The blast
for residents of this enormous a
block up here, their shattered w
and things like that.
This is just one of the impact p
It does appear, judging by what
the Ukrainian military has said,
this was a coordinated Russian
missile attack,
at least 81
missiles of different kinds,
cruise missiles, air launched mi
sea launched missiles as well.
Those Iranian made shaheed drone
that hit in cities from Kiev
here, the capital to Lviv in the
where at least five people
who reported killed
the southern city of Odessa,
the northern city of Kharkiv,
and that the power infrastructur
appears to have been
one of the targets of these stri
And that is a trend that we have
for months now
with Russia
apparently trying to knock out p
in this country.
And 15% of power
was, for example,
knocked out here in Kiev in anot
Shuttle-Mir, about 150,000 peopl
without electricity.
But I can just describe
to you,
traveling around Keefe today,
it's business as usual.
The restaurants are open,
businesses are open as well.
But I think what we see here
just underscore
was how haphazard and dangerous
it is when the Russians fired
these missiles.
Times is going to spin around ov
real fast.
I mean, there's a
there's a children's playground
right here.
Fortunately,
no kids would have been here
at 6:00 in the morning.
The Ukrainian military says
that they were able
to use their air defense
to knock down
at least 34 of the cruise missil
and four of those Iranian made
shaheed so-called suicide drones
But take a listen
to what a spokesperson for Ukrai
Air Force has to say
about the vulnerability they hav
some of these Russian missiles.
We watched as you can see,
the attack is really large scale
and for the first time
using such different types of mi
that we see that
this time as many as six kids we
So this is an attack
like I don't remember seeing bef
but it still is
different types of aircraft
where you used
strategic long range of maybe 31
There were 81 missile launches.
Initially,
there were 22,
which we can shoot down
We can't shoot down the Kinzel e
Sometimes the water
as he says,
they have no defenses
against some of these Russian mi
Back to you, Poppy.
Ivan, before you go,
I mean,
we just heard from the director
of National Intelligence
Avril Haines testifying
before Congress yesterday,
talking about real concerns abou
unlikely to make major gains,
but to continue this war of attr
to continue
killing civilians, to continue
trying to make this impossible
for Ukraine to live through.
And also real concerns
about Ukraine's efforts
in a counteroffensive
and you're seeing that play
out on the ground right now.
Yeah.
I mean, well,
let's just consider this
this missile barrage.
What does it accomplish?
The power is still on in much of
This is
just the most recent of a series
of these kind of missile attacks
So what is it really accomplish?
It keeps the air defenses active
It definitely terrifies local pe
I was talking to an elderly lady
who walked past and she
she said,
I have no words for how frighten
it was at 6:00 in the morning
when this missile part smashed d
But to date,
the Russian
military has not been able
to knock out the electricity
in Ukraine,
despite the scale of the destruc
and the battle that's been going
They have not succeeded in this,
They try again and again and aga
I leave that to you to judge
how effective
this strategy is,
unless it is to terrify the popu
and try to hobble the economy he
Yeah, terrify and terrorize.
And it's so striking to see you
in front of the children's
playground there
where it's all playing out.
Ivan, thank you for the reportin
Joining us
now this morning,
CNN military
analyst and former
member of a joint
staff at the Pentagon
and retired Colonel Cedric Leigh
Colonel, thank you for joining u
this morning.
Let's talk about the scale
of this attack.
It really spans
a full interior of Ukraine.
Talk about
where these strikes hit
and why
Russia chose these particular ta
Yeah, Don, good morning.
Well,
you know,
as Ivan mentioned in his report,
that really struck all across Uk
And you can see from the Western
is all the way
to the northeastern Kharkiv
and then down south in Odessa.
Plus, of course, the capital in
All of these areas are critical
to Ukraine from an economic stan
Many of them
do not have military installatio
But the very fact that they're b
indicates that
the Russian strategy is one
in which they're going
after all the different civilian
infrastructure installations
that they can hit.
You know, the key fact,
of course, they're going after p
not very effective, as Ivan ment
you know, in the aggregate.
But it's still,
you know,
at the very least, an inconvenie
and of course, can be
a fatal inconvenience
when these missiles strike
in an apartment areas
and in other inhabited areas.
Well, let's talk about Lviv.
I remember being there and leave
was seen to be, as, you know,
a safe space here.
This is one of the five areas he
So this is a residential area
thought to be a safe space.
Why would Russia strike there?
So the reason
for that, Don, besides spreading
and really indicating to Ukraini
that there is no safe haven.
Notice
how closely visits to the Polish
Lviv is the main supply route in
for a lot of the weapons
that NATO
and the US
are supplying to the Ukrainians.
So it's a warning in some respec
to Ukraine
that their supply chain
can be hit by the Russians.
And the Lviv, of course, is righ
smack in the middle of that.
All right.
Let's look at
now this apparition,
a nuclear power plant,
the state of emergency.
This company says that this appa
nuclear power plant has once aga
been completely disconnected.
It's an emergency for them.
It's been
disconnected from the Ukrainian
grid due to Russian shelling.
That continues to be
a major concern here.
Yeah, it sure does, Don.
And of course,
if there is no power to the nucl
power plant,
that limits
the ability
and actually makes it impossible
to cool the reactor.
So if the reactor is not cooled,
the possibility exists
of a nuclear accident
of one type or another.
And you use the term accident
is probably overstating things,
but it is definitely a serious c
and could result in some radiati
leaving the area, kind of like F
I in in Japan, a few years ago.
This isn't your expertize
we've been discussing you and I
and you
with other members of our networ
have been talking about the
the types of weapons
that Russia is using here
in these strikes,
including cruise
missiles, anti-aircraft missiles
What do you know about it?
Yeah.
So there are a lot of different
systems, as the Ukrainian
spokesman mentioned.
There are a lot of them.
So let's look into a couple of t
The 22 air launch cruise missile
This is something that is design
by the Russians to go after ship
This is something that is not de
to attack civilian targets.
It is not designed to
even attack formations on the gr
But that is one of the key thing
And then right under that,
the 47 control,
that's an air launch cruise miss
It is a hypersonic
missile can travel up to 12 time
the speed of sound.
And it is also actually
both of these missiles
are actually nuclear capable.
Now, they don't have nuclear war
in this case,
but the conventional warheads
have caused a lot of damage.
And the Ukrainians have no
air defenses against them.